Là,
vous voyez la porte du bureau de l’éditeur.
Il ne sait pas que vous êtes là,
mais il saura immédiatement
POURQUOI
vous êtes là :
ça fait belle lurette
que vous auriez dû toucher vos droits d’auteur,
et il ne répond même plus
à vos e-mails.
Alors,
vous poussez très doucement la porte
tant que l'éditeur ne se rend compte de rien,
et dès qu’il vous aperçoit,
vous lui foncez dessus ;
vous sautez par dessus le bureau,
et vous lui faites un étranglement :
« Alors,
comme ça,
on oublie mes droits d’auteurs ? »
« Ils sont pas assez faibles comme ça,
zéro c’est mieux,
c’est ça ? »
Oh pardon, Haristote !
C’est pas exactement
ce que recommande Jack London,
mais c’est un peu ça.
Dans cette vidéo,
je vais vous donner
les 10 conseils de Jack London,
le génial autodidacte américain,
pour devenir écrivain.
Je suis Romain,
voici Haristote
- qui joue le rôle de l’éditeur -
et vous êtes sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Comment
devenir écrivain ?
Quelles sont les choses
CONCRÈTES
À FAIRE,
pour réussir,
ce qui est très rare,
à vivre de sa plume ?
Jack London nous dit
comment il s’y est pris, lui,
dans Profession : écrivain,
une compilation de quatre-vingt-treize textes
issus de ses correspondances,
ou d’articles qu’il avait écrits
pour de petites revues.
Je l’avais lu il y a pile dix ans,
et je l’ai relu récemment
parce qu’il est maintenant disponible
sur Kindle.
Comme je le fais systématiquement
depuis les quelques vidéos précédentes,
je vous permets de télécharger
mes notes de lecture,
en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou sur celui qui est dans la description,
puis en me laissant votre adresse e-mail.
Les conseils de Jack London
sont d’autant plus précieux
qu’il est parti de tout en bas,
lui :
issu d’un milieu très populaire,
il a quitté l’école très tôt
pour travailler ;
il a vécu dans la pauvreté,
sans savoir s’il pourrait manger à sa faim,
et malgré l’ampleur de l’adversité,
il a réussi à devenir
un des romanciers
les plus importants de son époque,
et probablement
un des plus grands auteurs américains.
Le site Ranker le classe
huitième meilleur écrivain américain
de tous les temps,
et le journal britannique The Telegraph
a classé son roman L’Appel de la forêt,
l’histoire d’un chien domestique
qui redevient sauvage
- ça me fait penser à Haristote,
même si je ne donne pas cher de sa peau
dans une forêt -
donc The Telegraph
a classé L’Appel de la forêt
cinquième meilleur roman nord-américain
de tous les temps.
Et enfin,
autre chose que j’ai découverte récemment,
la bibliothèque de la Pléiade
a accueilli Jack London en 2016,
une consécration qui veut un peu dire
qu’il est considéré
comme un des plus grands auteurs
TOUT COURT.
Et je rappelle
que Jack London
s’est lancé dans l’aventure littéraire
SANS avoir fait d’études,
sans mentor
ni réseau,
contre l’avis de tout son entourage,
qui était très populaire,
et enfin,
SANS ARGENT !
Donc si quelqu’un a de bons conseils
pour devenir écrivain,
c’est bien lui.
Alors,
j’ai synthétisé les recommandations
qui sont dans ce livre,
et je suis arrivé à une liste de dix conseils,
qui sont à la fois pratiques
et précis
- c’est vraiment de l’or !
En toute franchise,
si je n’ai pas précisément pour ambition
de devenir écrivain,
j’applique moi-même
les conseils de Jack London
parce qu’ils sont très efficaces.
Dans cette vidéo,
je vais vous les présenter
dans l’ordre dans lequel
le débutant devrait les appliquer
pour devenir écrivain
- c’est-à-dire un ordre de priorité.
Et puis je vous révèlerai
dans le dixième
et dernier conseil
pourquoi il peut être nécessaire
d’apprendre un sport de combat
pour les rendez-vous avec l’éditeur
- donc regardez bien la vidéo jusqu’au
bout.
Allez,
on rentre dans le vif du sujet :
CONSEIL N°1.
Mettez un pouce bleu
et abonnez-vous,
si vous voulez
que je relâche l’éditeur !
Le premier conseil de Jack London
- ça ne vous étonnera pas -
c’est de lire beaucoup.
Bah oui,
l’écrivain est d’abord
un LISEUR.
Jack London a appris à lire à cinq ans,
et étant donné ses moyens modestes,
il a emprunté beaucoup d’ouvrages
dans les bibliothèques publiques
avant d’être en mesure d’en acquérir.
Il avait toujours un livre avec lui,
ce qui n’était pas commun
dans son milieu social ;
et il a même pris l’habitude,
à l’âge adulte,
de passer les dernières heures de la journée
avec des livres,
dans son lit.
Plus généralement,
pour devenir écrivain,
il faut étudier
et se cultiver
tout au long de a vie.
Dans ce travail intellectuel,
il faut notamment analyser
l’état de la littérature de l’époque
dans le but de modéliser
les écrivains professionnels
- c’est-à-dire de reprendre
les principes
et les recettes
qui ont fait leur succès.
Et UN PRINCIPE,
en particulier,
est CRUCIAL.
« Je livre TOUJOURS
la copie promise. »,
affirme Jack London
- au moins ça c’est clair.
C’est que l’autodidacte américain
est très discipliné.
À ses yeux,
l’écrivain professionnel
est un homme comme les autres :
il doit se plier
à la discipline d’un métier.
Cette discipline,
elle a quatre composantes principales :
la première,
c’est la régularité.
L’aspirant écrivain
ne doit pas attendre l’inspiration ;
il doit la harceler
en se mettant au travail
quel que soit
son niveau de motivation.
« Imposez-vous une besogne
et veillez à l’accomplir chaque jour,
vous aurez plus de mots à votre crédit
à la fin de l’année »
Jack London recommande plus précisément
d’écrire mille mots par jour
- À CONDITION
que ces mots
soient les meilleurs qu’on puisse trouver.
Pourquoi mille mots ?
Parce qu'en dessous,
les choses n’avancent pas assez vite ;
et qu’au-dessus,
la qualité de la production littéraire
baisse rapidement.
Si vous avez regardé ma vidéo
sur les règles d’écriture de Stephen King,
vous vous rappelez peut-être
que l’il écrit lui deux mille mots
chaque jour
- la différence c’est,
je crois,
que Jack London
mise peut-être davantage
sur la qualité.
Deuxième composante
de la discipline de l’écrivain :
écrire UNE SEULE histoire à la fois.
Jack London propose la méthode suivante :
vous noircissez vos mille mots chaque jour,
sans penser au résultat final,
et cela pendant quatre-vingt dix jours ;
et au bout de cette durée,
vous retirez le tiers le moins bon,
soit trente mille mots.
Et puis cette méthode s’insère
dans une stratégie plus globale :
vous faites des tests successifs
de quatre-vingt dix jours
- deux mois de travail,
puis un mois de repos entre guillemets,
pour récupérer et réfléchir.
Troisième composante :
prendre des notes !
Vous devez TOUJOURS
avoir un carnet de notes
à portée de main
- mieux,
il doit être comme une extension
de votre corps.
Aujourd’hui,
un smartphone
et une application de prise de notes
- moi j’utilise Evernote par exemple -
c’est quand même bien pratique.
Quatrième et dernière composante
de la discipline de l’écrivain :
rester en bonne santé.
C’est même CRUCIAL
pour mettre en pratique
le conseil suivant.
Le talent,
ça n’existe pas
- la seule chose
à la quelle croit Jack London,
c’est le labeur
ACHARNÉ.
« Le travail est tout ;
c’est la sanctification et le salut.
Écrivez ce mot en majuscules,
TRAVAIL,
TRAVAIL tout le temps ».
Le débutant doit d’autant plus charbonner
qu’il est peut-être
dans la même urgence économique
que Jack London à ses débuts.
D’ailleurs,
s’il n’a pas les moyens
de se consacrer à l’écriture à plein
temps,
il ne faut pas qu’il quitte son emploi ;
il faut plutôt
qu’il mise sur L'INTENSITÉ
et LA RÉGULARITÉ du travail
pour compenser le manque de temps.
Mais la raison principale
pour laquelle il faut travailler comme un
fou,
c’est que l’éditeur
N’A PAS ENVIE
de vous donner votre chance.
Pour réduire le risque économique,
il privilégie les auteurs
qui ont DÉJÀ un nom,
c’est-à-dire une base de lecteurs fidèles
- donc l’auteur inconnu,
lui,
doit forcément proposer un travail
d’une qualité supérieure,
telle qu’elle compense
son absence de notoriété initiale.
Il faut donc travailler comme un fou
pour devenir écrivain ;
après,
il ne faut pas non plus
y aller la tête dans le guidon.
Comme il a commencé dans la pauvreté,
Jack London est assez pragmatique :
l’écriture est une activité commerciale,
avec des producteurs
et des consommateurs.
Alors certes,
il existe des auteurs
qui croient à l’Art pour l’art,
qui sont là pour délivrer un message
- mais ils sont généralement
à l’abri du besoin,
ce qui n’est pas le cas
de la majorité des aspirants écrivains.
Le débutant
qui doit remplir son frigo
N’A PAS LE CHOIX
de sa démarche économique :
il doit partir du besoin du marché.
Pour Jack London,
l’écrivain est un « marchand d’idées
»,
et l’argent n’est donc pas un tabou pour
lui.
Il met sur le marché
des productions COMMERCIALES
- typiquement de la fiction,
ce qui se vend le mieux,
et surtout pas des essais
ou de la poésie.
Dans le détail,
l’aspirant écrivain a aussi intérêt
à conformer son histoire
à certains critères
pour en maximiser la valeur marchande.
Jack London conseille,
entre autres :
de s’inspirer systématiquement de la réalité
;
de rendre le récit réaliste,
quitte à choquer le bourgeois ;
de développer
la psychologie des personnages ;
ou encore,
éventuellement de s’appuyer
sur une idéologie
qui est dans l’air du temps.
Inutile,
en revanche,
d’aspirer à diffuser la vérité,
si le but est de vendre des livres.
C’est qu’on a tendance,
d’après Jack London,
à sous-estimer L'INCULTURE
de la masse démocratique des lecteurs.
Il s’exprime d'ailleurs assez crûment
sur ce point :
« C’est le troupeau
où règnent la fantaisie et le caprice,
la marotte et la mode,
c’est la masse instable,
incohérente,
parlant et pensant comme la foule,
les « singes »,
excusez-moi,
du temps présent.
»
Donc manifestement,
il n’est pas nécessaire
de respecter son lectorat
pour lui vendre beaucoup de livres.
Quand on s’engage
dans la carrière des lettres,
il ne faut pas chercher à écrire un classique
;
simplement travailler avec humilité
pour progresser,
et en particulier améliorer son style.
Aucun éditeur ne donnera sa chance
à un débutant
sous prétexte qu’il fait de gros efforts
- et s’il lui donne sa chance pour cette
raison,
il commet une faute
- pas une faute morale,
mais une faute économique.
À l’époque de Jack London,
on pouvait commencer
de deux manières différentes :
la première,
la plus brillante,
c'était d’écrire directement
un livre à succès ;
et la seconde,
la plus sûre
- celle qu’a choisi
l’autodidacte américain -
c'était de se démarquer
d’abord avec de bonnes nouvelles
dans les magazines.
Donc Jack London
a commencé petit :
il a d’abord accompli
beaucoup de « besogne littéraire »
pour gagner sa vie
- en plus,
personne ne l’a aidé,
donc il n’a pu avancer
que par essai et erreur.
À côté,
il participait aussi à des concours littéraires
- parfois, il gagnait,
et ça lui donnait bon espoir.
Or, il n’y pas dix mille moyens
de réussir en commençant petit :
il faut PERSÉVÉRER.
J’ai hésité
à fusionner ce conseil avec le troisième
- « travailler comme un fou » -
mais je trouve finalement
que ce n’est pas la même chose
de travailler intensément,
et puis de réussir à le faire dans la durée,
en dépit de l’accumulation
des obstacles
et des échecs.
Et puis Jack London
insiste bien sur ce point :
non seulement l’aspirant écrivain
va devoir travailler comme un fou,
mais SURTOUT,
il ne va pas être publié
au bout d’une semaine
- enfin si,
ça existe,
mais ça s’appelle la publication
à compte d’auteur,
et ça confine parfois
à l’escroquerie
- mais bon,
c’est pas le sujet.
Pour devenir un vrai écrivain,
il faut
UN « COEUR DE LION »
pour persévérer dans l’adversité.
Jack London,
lui,
à ses débuts,
il n’arrêtait pas d’écrire,
et à peu près de tout.
Il essuyait REFUS
SUR REFUS,
au point qu’il n’avait plus de timbres
pour répondre
lorsqu’il a finalement reçu
les premières lettres positives
des rédacteurs en chef.
C’est qui très difficile,
c’est de MAINTENIR
au long cours
un rythme de production ÉLEVÉ
sans compromettre la qualité.
Il ne faut pas se satisfaire de ses travaux,
et les envoyer
pour les envoyer,
sans être certain d’avoir traqué,
puis corrigé,
la moindre des imperfections
- et même après avoir tout corrigé,
il ne faut pas être satisfait.
Le débutant ambitieux
doit développer son perfectionnisme :
« Celui qui n’est pas satisfait,
est le seul à faire des choses.
Celui qui est satisfait
ne fait rien.
L’absence de satisfaction
est le stimulant de la réalisation.
La satisfaction est destruction
et l’antichambre de la mort ».
En fait,
c’est pareil dans tous les domaines :
les meilleurs travaillent sans relâche,
ils se perdent dans le travail,
jusqu’à ce que les honneurs leur tombent
dessus
et que leur nom soit
sur toutes les lèvres.
Vous vous souvenez
des tests de quatre-vingt-dix jours
dont j’ai parlés
à propos de la discipline de l’écrivain
?
Eh bien Jack London
recommande d’en mener
pendant au moins cinq ans.
Il faut bien autant de temps
pour apprendre un métier manuel !
MAIS c’est vrai
que le niveau de persévérance nécessaire
pour devenir écrivain
est probablement
BIEN supérieur.
C’est dans son roman autobiographique
Martin Eden
que Jack London a décrit
la persévérance SURHUMAINE
dont il a dû faire preuve,
et toutes les déceptions qu’il a éprouvées,
avant de finalement réussir
à convaincre les rédacteurs en chef
et les éditeurs.
Jack London est surtout reconnu
pour ses histoires d’aventure
- des histoires originales
qui font voyager le lecteur.
Mais l’histoire ne fait pas tout
- il faut la transmettre
dans la forme la plus AGRÉABLE possible.
L’aspirant écrivain doit donc
travailler son style.
Or, la qualité de l’écriture
découle de celle de la pensée
- l’amélioration du style passe donc
par celle de la pensée.
Et pour ça,
j’en ai parlé dans le premier conseil :
il faut lire
et étudier
toute la vie.
MAIS dans l’immédiat,
pour le style,
il faut encore partir
de ce que veut le public.
Que demande le lecteur moderne ?
Que l’auteur entre
TRÈS VITE
dans le vif du sujet ;
que l’histoire ne foisonne pas
de détails superflus,
et qu’on le laisse
utiliser son imagination ;
qu’on lui épargne
les digressions philosophiques
ou morales
en plein milieu du récit.
Le lecteur moderne est un adulte
qui réfléchit
de manière INDÉPENDANTE.
Comme Jack London est darwiniste,
il rapporte l’évolution du style littéraire
à celle de l’espèce.
Or,
le moteur de l’évolution de l’espèce,
c’est la recherche de l’efficience,
c’est-à-dire de l’économie de temps
- de la même manière
que le progrès technique
raccourcit les processus
en les simplifiant,
le style littéraire évolue par la concentration
et la concision.
À l’ALLÉGORIE,
c’est-à-dire l’expression d’un concept
par une histoire,
se substitue la MÉTAPHORE,
qui se contente d’une image
pour incarner l’idée.
Un autre phénomène notable
de cette évolution du style,
c’est la disparition progressive
des pléonasmes.
Et sur le plan statistique,
l’évolution se traduit
par une baisse continue
du nombre de mots par phrase.
Ça c’est l’évolution au niveau micro,
comme disent les économistes ;
mais elle se retrouve aussi
au niveau macro,
c’est-à-dire à l’échelle du livre :
l’ère du roman-fleuve,
en plusieurs volumes,
comme Les Misérables
(qui fait mille trois-cent pages),
cette ère est révolue.
Les romans de l’époque de Jack London
font eux entre quarante mille
et soixante mille mots,
de telle sorte
qu’ils peuvent être lus d’une seule traite
- et je crois
que c’est encore la norme
pour les romans actuels.
Donc bien sûr,
le conseil de Jack London,
c’est d’épouser l’air du temps,
pour donner au lecteur
exactement ce qu’il veut.
Après,
il rappelle quand même
certaines règles élémentaires
qui sont intemporelles,
notamment :
diversifier le vocabulaire
pour éviter les répétitions ;
varier les structures de phrase ;
faire l’effort
de chercher des images ;
ou encore
réaliser les omissions
avec finesse.
Si on veut vraiment soigner le style,
donner une forme agréable
au récit,
ça implique,
à l’échelle du projet du livre,
de ne pas écrire en une seule traite
- il faut laisser MÛRIR le manuscrit.
La particularité du processus créatif
de Jack London,
c'est qu’il essaie d’atteindre
un niveau élevé de qualité
LE PLUS TÔT possible.
Pour ça,
il rédige TRÈS LENTEMENT
à la main ;
ensuite,
il corrige son premier jet
en dactylographiant
le manuscrit,
ce qui fait
qu’il a une version quasi finale
en seulement DEUX étapes de production
- il modifie très rarement
les épreuves.
Pour Jack London,
l’écrivain à succès
a forcément une VÉRITABLE originalité
- et cette originalité,
c’est une forme de sincérité
qu’il puise dans son expérience vécue
et dans la réalité factuelle.
C’est sa
« philosophie de la vie ».
« Tout écrivain ayant eu du succès
de façon permanente
a possédé cette philosophie.
»
L’écrivain digne de ce nom a
sa PROPRE manière
de voir le monde
– une manière certes subjective,
et pas forcément enseignable,
mais si particulière
qu’elle produit un élargissement
de la conscience du lecteur.
Cette subjectivité inédite,
c’est même le fil conducteur
de son oeuvre
- c’est ce qui peut,
s’il est en résonance avec l’époque,
lui donner une portée UNIVERSELLE
et la rendre ainsi IMMORTELLE.
On voit avec ce conseil
que si Jack London est très pragmatique,
il reconnaît quand même
une forme de transcendance à l’écriture.
Bon après,
comment DÉVELOPPER
sa philosophie de vie ?
Il faut d’abord
élargir ses perspectives sur l’existence
en cultivant à la fois la connaissance
et l’expérience
- « poser la main
sur le pouls intérieur des choses »,
écrit Jack London.
Alors,
c’est sûr que
ça ne va pas se produire
en regardant Netflix
- la tâche est immense,
MAIS on gaspille
tellement de temps,
et puis c’est le prix de la richesse
et du prestige.
Bon,
on ne va pas se mentir :
l’aspirant écrivain ne se met pas à la
littérature
parce que les Muses
sont venues le voir la nuit dernière
- dans quatre-vingt-dix-neuf pour cent des
cas,
il s’y met par ambition.
Il est attiré par l’aisance financière
et/ou le prestige des auteurs à succès.
Ensuite,
quand il commence,
sa première obsession,
c’est de vivre de sa plume.
Mais bon,
l’obsession est la même
dans toute la chaîne de production :
le propriétaire du journal,
celui de la maison d’édition ;
le rédacteur en chef,
l’éditeur,
les correcteurs,
les critiques,
et puis même les lecteurs,
tout le monde a la même motivation
- donc il faut l’accepter.
Jack London,
lui,
n’a aucun problème avec ça :
en ancien pauvre,
il défend le bien-être matériel
de l’écrivain professionnel.
Lui-même veille à ses intérêts
avec un certain sens des affaires :
il négocie son tarif
(habituellement dix cents le mot)
systématiquement à la hausse ;
dès qu’il peut,
il compte plusieurs mots
au lieu d’un seul ;
et puis il conteste par principe
le décompte de l’éditeur ;
enfin,
il n’hésite pas à monnayer sa renommée,
par exemple quand il démarche des magazines
pour financer ses voyages,
en leur proposant
de sponsoriser son bateau à prix d'or
- il ne leur fait vraiment
pas de cadeaux.
Mais bon,
il faut assumer la quête du prestige,
parce qu’il est mérité
après tant d’efforts.
« Qu’il soit matérialiste ou idéaliste,
aucun écrivain normal n’est insensible
aux avantages attachés
à sa possession [l’atout du nom].
»
Jack London n’a pas de mots assez durs
pour décrire les hypocrites :
ce sont des « sophistes et des dégénérés
».
Pour autant,
le débutant ne doit pas
chercher à réussir à n’importe quel prix
:
il doit refuser
la promotion par le scandale,
le sacrifice de la qualité littéraire
à un profit rapide,
ou encore une starification artificielle.
Toute la difficulté,
pour lui,
sera de satisfaire le public
en restant fidèle
à sa philosophie de la vie.
Imaginons qu’Haristote
soit un éditeur :
là,
je le…
Oh non…
il a assez souffert comme ça…
…et puis il ne serait jamais aussi dur
qu’un rédacteur en chef
ou un éditeur !
Ces hommes
ont tellement fait souffrir Jack London
qu’il les qualifie de « criminels ».
Et il énumère leurs crimes :
répondre beaucoup trop tard
à l’aspirant écrivain ;
ne pas lui répondre,
et laisser moisir le manuscrit pendant des
mois ;
s’ils daignent lire le manuscrit,
ils l’annotent tellement
qu’ils le rendent inutilisable ;
parfois,
oh miracle,
ils l’envoient directement à l’imprimerie…
…MAIS sans fournir un exemplaire à l’auteur,
ou sans respecter le délai de paiement,
ou sans avoir obtenu son accord sur le tarif,
voire en décidant
que c’est une contribution gratuite.
« Les rédacteurs en chef de magazines
sont des hommes d’affaires durs
et sans principes.
»
Si Jack London est conscient
de l’aléa qui pèse sur le succès d’un
livre,
il part du principe
que les rédacteurs en chef
et les éditeurs ont pour objectif
de s’enrichir sur son dos.
Or,
seuls les écrivains de premier ordre
réussissent à inverser le rapport de forces.
Par exemple,
Jack London vendait suffisamment de livres
pour se permettre de refuser
les corrections de ses éditeurs,
qu’il trouvait souvent excessives
ou erronées.
En revanche,
son succès ne le rendait pas moins impuissant
face à la malhonnêteté
des critiques littéraires,
qui sont considérés
comme les juges
de la valeur finale de l’œuvre.
Avec lui comme avec les autres,
ils ne font pas sérieusement leur travail,
quand ils ne s’épargnent pas
purement et simplement
l’étape de la lecture.
Jack London raconte par exemple
qu’un critique a écrit un éloge enthousiaste
de certaines de ses nouvelles
sur la ruée vers l’or,
en croyant qu’il s’agissait
d’histoires de mer.
Et le pire dans tout ça,
c’est que
comme les critiques ne font pas leur travail,
certains écrivains lui demandent alors
À LUI
de se muer en critique
- pour ensuite lui reprocher
sa franchise.
Bref,
rédacteur en chef,
éditeur,
critique,
et même écrivain,
il n’y en a pas un
pour rattraper l’autre.
Donc méfiance !
En synthèse,
pour devenir écrivain
il faut :
lire et étudier
en permanence ;
être discipliné ;
travailler comme un fou ;
partir des besoins du public ;
commencer petit ;
persévérer ;
cultiver un style
simple et efficace ;
avoir une philosophie de vie ;
assumer la quête de la richesse
et du prestige ;
et enfin,
se méfier
du monde de la littérature.
Alors,
les dix conseils de Jack London
rejoignent ceux donnés
par d’autres grands auteurs
- comme ceux de Stephen King,
que j’ai synthétisés dans une autre vidéo
que vous pouvez voir
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
soit sur celui qui est dans la description
-
donc,
les conseils de Jack London
sont cohérents avec l’expérience commune
de l’écrivain professionnel,
défini comme la personne
qui réussit à vivre de sa plume ;
MAIS ils se démarquent quand même
par un grand pragmatisme.
En autodidacte parvenu à la gloire littéraire
à la force du poignet,
il s'exprime sans tabou
- il parle de « marché littéraire »,
il insulte son lectorat ;
il justifie l’ambition de l’écrivain,
son esprit mercantile et sa vanité ;
il dénonce la corruption
du monde littéraire.
C’est que,
comme je l’ai dit en introduction,
il a eu,
lui qui est parti de si bas,
à déplacer des montagnes
pour s’imposer.
Son ascension a été si dure
que la profession d’écrivain
en est démystifiée :
devenir écrivain,
c’est un peu un projet
comme un autre ;
son accomplissement tient,
en définitive,
à un mélange
de réalisme
et de persévérance.
Merci d’avoir regardé la vidéo jusqu’au
bout !
J’espère vraiment
que les conseils de Jack London
peuvent vous aider dans vos projets d’écriture.
Si la vidéo vous a plu,
et SURTOUT,
si vous voulez récompenser Haristote
dans son rôle de l’éditeur
agressé par l’auteur,
vous pouvez donner un pouce bleu à la vidéo,
vous abonner à la chaîne
si vous aimez la vulgarisation
de la pensée,
et enfin peut-être
laisser un petit commentaire.
Je vous permets également
de télécharger
mes notes de lectures,
comme je le fais systématiquement
depuis les quelques vidéos précédentes.
Si vous voulez lire
ma synthèse écrite détaillée
du livre
qui est sur le blog,
ou si vous souhaitez le lire directement,
tous les liens sont dans la description.
Je suis Romain,
je suis avec mon fidèle Haristote,
qui est quand même
bien plus gentil qu’un éditeur,
et sous étiez
sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Vous n’avez pas besoin
de persévérer autant que Jack London
pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée
sans vous prendre la tête.